[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
femmes et ruralité en finir avec les
zones blanches de l'égalité
déficit de mobilité emploi précaire
difficultés d'accès aux services publics
renoncement aux soins
la délégation aux droits des femmes
alerte sur la situation préoccupante des
11 millions de femmes vivant dans un
territoire rural soit l'équivalent d'une
française sur trois
constatant l'absence du sujet de
l'égalité femmes hommes au sein de
l'agenda real la délégation a publié le
14 octobre 2021 un rapport d'information
intitulée femmes et ruralité en finir
avec les zones blanches de l'égalité
la question de la mobilité est central
dans la lutte contre les inégalités
en zone rurale seuls 80 % des femmes
sont détentrices du permis b contre 90 %
des hommes
cela signifie qu'elles subissent un
accès plus compliqué à l'emploi aux
services publics aux soins
forts de ce constat les sénateurs
plaident notamment pour le développement
d'une offre de transport public ponctuel
l'autorisation des arrêts à la demande
ou encore le développement de
plateformes de covoiturage scolaire
les élus ont en outre relevé que les
jeunes filles en zone rurale avait un
champ d'opportunités plus limité dans
tous les domaines
pour remédier à ce déséquilibre
le rapport recommande de mener des
campagnes d'information à l'orientation
qui inverse les stéréotypes d'encourager
les dispositifs de mentorat et les
partenariats d'associations ou encore de
créer des dispositifs innovants pour
permettre aux jeunes ruraux de suivre au
moins deux années d'études supérieures à
proximité de leur domicile
en milieu rural l'inégalité des chances
observe ensuite dans le monde du travail
les femmes sont souvent concernés par
des emplois précaires ou à temps partiel
subi
ces caractéristiques engendre un risque
accru de pauvreté pour les femmes de ces
territoires et donc de dépendance
financière vis-à-vis de leur conjoint
le but est de garantir un meilleur
équilibre entre les femmes et les hommes
au sein des filières à haut potentiel
d'emplois dans les territoires ruraux
numérique métiers verts
en outre les sénateurs constatent que
les femmes éloignées des grands centres
urbains sont les premières victimes de
la désertification médicale
aussi la délégation recommande de
généraliser à tous les départements
ruraux les solutions de médecine
itinérante de développer des télés
consultations gynécologiques et
d'adopter des mesures pour inciter les
médecins à s'installer en zone rurale
lorsqu'elles sont victimes de violences
intrafamiliales
les femmes en milieu rural sont
également moins protégés
la délégation préconise de développer au
sein des gendarmerie des brigades
spécialisées dans la lutte contre les
violences conjugales sexuelle et sexiste
d'augmenter le nombre de places
d'hébergement d'urgence ou de pérenniser
le système de points d'accueil dans les
centres commerciaux pour les femmes
victimes de violences
enfin le rapport formule plusieurs
recommandations concrètes pour accroître
la mixité dans la vie politique locale
des territoires ruraux
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport de la délégation aux
droits des femmes
[Musique]